Peter says shouldn't we invest in the
things we use a lot instead of
minimizing them buying a coffee machine
is much cheaper than buying a coffee
than buying a coffee every time we want
one now I just buy a new coffee machine
every morning to get that the freshest
cut possible yeah I wanted to taste like
plastic a little bit like I'm gonna buy
a new shirt every day we were in Toronto
the guy who owned the venue there he
used to be in a so we were on tour last
year the guy who owned the venue in
Toronto he used to be in some metal band
they would go out touring and he said
the the thing that was most precious on
their Rider was a new pair of socks and
a new shirt like a pack of new black
shirts every day because apparently when
you're a rock band with six or seven
dudes living out of a van you don't
shower a whole lot and so you just
change your underwear he's not at the
top of the list no you change your
underwear you change your shirt but
otherwise no I mean it and I think the
same goes for my clothes I mean I own
the shirt that I'm wearing here the the
same is true I have a I make coffee at
home they'd coffee at home this morning
and we're not saying don't own anything
we're trying to figure out we're trying
to parse out so this essay on our
website recently the you saw cuz I saw
you tweet about it but essential
non-essential and junk basically and
figuring out what's essential for you
and it's gonna be different from me
versus Ryan versus Ryan number two and
and each of us are gonna have something
different especially in the second
category which is non-essential things
that add value to our lives most of us
have the same fundamental needs for
housing and food and and your clothing
but then beyond that what adds value to
our life they're non-essentials I don't
have to have this glass I could go to
the fountain and stick my head under it
and drink that way but this adds value
to my life so having this glass is a
non-essential but some of the adds value
the problem is the third category which
is probably 90 plus percent of the stuff
that we own yeah is junk and we pretend
it adds value or here's the other thing
there's almost this weird in-between
area where there are these non
essentials that are actually we don't
use
most of the time and I think that's
where you come in and you say okay maybe
you do get value from it but maybe you
only get value from it once a month or
once a year why why let it take up all
that extra space in the meantime and I
think coffee machines also like to use
this specific example like if you're in
the coffee that's a great thing to own
like I've loved my coffee machine
you know I researched them I'm excited
about them and I think I think it's
important that people know that like
from our from our perspective I think
you guys agree it's like the things that
you love and the things that you want to
own and that you care about are things
that are good and you know healthy and
that's a great thing to invest in for
sure so going with this same example
like I'm thinking about so I've got a
coffee set up but I do pour over because
it's one glass and I don't wasto packs
every sixty uh Kaleta nopalina
yeah it's like a colita it's like the
blue bottle yeah the blue bottle Kaleta
I think it's still considered to colita
I don't know I should know this stuff
owning a coffee shop but uh but you know
I don't have a like a coffee maker and
when I have I mean there's one point I
had my mom my grandmother and three
siblings staying with us and all of them
drank coffee so sitting here make it six
pour I was like good grief leg I need to
get a coffee machine but I was like I'm
not gonna buy a coffee machine
yeah just for this every once in a while
thing where I got guests who all drink
coffee and it's a pain in the butt to
make all these pour overs but a thing
like being able to rent one and have one
delivered from Omni and two hours in my
house man that is that's that's a
perfect solution yeah or or now with you
have these apps like a post mates or
something you could get six cups of
coffee delivered probably I don't know
yeah exactly how that would work with
with coffee but I assume that you could
do that as well and so there's sort of
like these now if you had six people
living with you every day then that'd be
the first story then you would need a
different solution you know for me I
have I have I do two separate pour overs
v6 these in the morning one for me one
for Becks and I don't wait too late
because I have a coffee with her so I
don't want to make one and make a second
one and so I just have to set up and
that's what works well for me I use it
every day that is something that is
non-essential but it is pretty damn
close to essential at this point I think
about what am I thinking about these
the first time I really thought about
the the junk what Ryan and you and I
came with the the 20/20 rule the just in
case rule anything that you don't need
you can replace for less than twenty
dollars in less than 20 minutes or
apparently if Omni is in your city you
can also replace it or temporarily
replace it the when I was going on my
honeymoon so I was 22 years old you
remember you were in my wedding yes with
the strut which is a stretch Escalade no
was a stretch homework oh yeah that's
right it's yeah we were at the pinnacle
we're at peak consumption in my early
early to mid 20s it's so terrible anyway
like I remember going on the honeymoon
and my spouse and I we both over packed
but she over packed significantly she
had the biggest suitcase you know
someone got us these suitcases for for
your wedding yeah as wedding gifts and
was like the this collection of
suitcases from extra large to small
basically they like nests like
yeah they were but they were more
terrifying because that you could fill
them with stuff right and and so the the
the largest one she had and of course if
you have the largest one you feel
compelled to fill it right with
everything right and so she just trimmed
it and I had the necklace so she had the
extra-large I had the large I filled
mine up with stuff as well and then she
had the medium which she tried to use as
a carry-on but they wouldn't let her
because it was too big and then I had
the small which I used as a carry-on in
addition to like bringing a laptop bag
with me this is a one week honeymoon in
Mexico and for some reason I have a suit
with me and I have like all of these
these extra like four pairs of swimming
trunks because of course I'm gonna write
a different pair every day right and
like if the first three pair get dirty
me a fourth hole of shirts and khaki
using what I didn't even think of what
am i doing it's like I've got the space
I have to feel I feel cold to fill it so
we get to the airport we're flying out
of Cincinnati so we drove down to
Cincinnati which is the since I Air
Force action in Kentucky and she puts
her bag up on the scale
and it's 70 pounds they're like ma'am
you can't we can't take this much stuff
and so they put my bag up there and it's
40 pounds well the limit at the time was
50 pounds and so we had to remove ten
pounds from her bag and put it in my bag
we're gonna remove ten pounds from her
other bag and put it on her carry-on bag
which then she had to check and so we
had yeah I'm doing the math real quick
in my head of damn-near 200 pounds worth
of stuff 150 pounds worth of stuff we
another human with us basically and I
can tell you that like most of that
stuff just got in the way which was like
the perfect metaphor was like I didn't
need didn't end up using much of this
stuff and some of the some of the stuff
I used I used just out of obligation
well I brought four pairs of swimming
trunks I might as well just alternate
through them and now it's like now I'll
bring one pair of workout slash swimming
trunks and it like they they serve
multiple functions and so I think when
we think about our access to stuff we're
okay with having an empty room like
you're complete without filling it it's
totally fine and in fact it's really
freeing I remember we did the the
packing party for Ryan when he like
first embraced minimal impact of all
this stuff as if he were moving and he
went over to his condo that big condo he
was talking about and it sounded
different because you like you remove
the superfluous sort of things that
dampen the sound and all of a sudden
you're like you have this like echo but
it was like a pleasant echo it was like
the echo you get from going to a
cathedral or something where all of a
sudden you're like oh this is this is
calming I've noticed that I've been
doing this video series on YouTube this
month this past month with doing
answering a video every day it's called
living room conversations and basically
I just turn on my phone camera and
answer one question a day in my living
room and there's someone's always
comments like it seems to be an echo in
there I'm like no [ __ ] I don't own
anything like that we own exactly what
we need and then also what adds value to
our lives but then we don't have the
superfluous stuff and hopefully there'll
be a service soon where if I do need
something then I can and I can bring it
into my home yeah
thinking about this this morning before
the podcast how like when I was in the
corporate world I would buy stuff to
fill the space because I had the space
but every time I bought something it was
like this this affirmation of like yeah
man you're making it you're living the
American dream you're able to do what
you want and yet before I knew it I had
a condo full of a bunch of stuff but man
when I finally removed it it felt so
good like being in and that's for me
some people like they like being around
clutter and that's fine but for me like
having an empty room some art on the
wall you know bookshelf a couch like
that's like I'm thinking about my living
room right now I mean it's it's pretty
empty but it is so much better like I
don't look at you know my art and think
man I wish I had 10 more paintings or I
wish I had two more couches or uh yeah I
I think that for someone who for someone
who who thinks that that sounds crazy
like try it out meaning like have your
own little packing party maybe in your
living room like think of the room that
you are in the most and and just pack up
as you know whatever you can and see
what it's like to have an empty room I'm
not like a huge believer in function
weight or anything like I really don't
know anything about function why but
like after that packing party I started
to get it I started to understand like
oh okay yeah like when I'm sitting here
on my laptop answering emails from work
like not having a big screen TV in front
of me to distract me it really helps me
to stay more focused it helps me feel
better I was teaching a writing class
this weekend one of the things I was
talking about was the conversation I
have with Donnell right [ __ ] is a
novelist from Chillicothe Ohio and he I
said well how do you like cuz he started
writing when he was 55 years old in this
really inspirational story like how how
do you like stay focus and he's like
just sit in the chair like those four
words totally changed my life with
respect to writing because what he was
really saying it was a metaphor for like
remove the distractions no Wi-Fi I don't
have your phone with you there's no TV
your radio on yeah it's just it's it's
removing the superfluous and then you
can bring those things back in when when
you truly need them as opposed to having
them this is the distractions turned on
as if it's a fireplace going all the
time it's
some glowing screens all around us and
and I get it it's really it's really
intriguing you know I've got a five year
old daughter and she loves watching
Peppa Pig and what's the new one she
watches Pocoyo is the the new the new
kids I guess it's special the new kids
crazy yeah it's on it's on YouTube and
she just loves watching it but I so I I
and the sad thing is like you know my
frontal cortex is fully developed and I
still get trapped by the the glowing
screen totally and and so it's been
amazing we just had a six month old son
and how quickly they developed that that
reflex to see a screen and like get into
it was incredible and the weird thing is
like you can't like if you were to if
you were to take them walking them past
a house where our sprinklers go just
going crazy they may not think a whole
lot of it but if they see that same
sprinkler on a television it's like like
they're just there's something about the
glowing screen that yeah it gets them
fully enamoured into this this this
other world blowing strains are the
pretty addictive man they are the I was
thinking about I was just in Missoula
and we got some friends each of them
have a two year old and watching them
use a cell phone and like how they can
hardly talk but they can but they can
use a cell phone pretty easily it's I
don't know is something something crazy
about the the experiment were they they
dropped off this is I believe in
Ethiopia they dropped off tablets and
the village in Ethiopia without any
instructions whatsoever and most of the
village was was illiterate and
especially little kids they they they
were not literate at all and they had no
instructions no no training and they
just dropped him off in the box and
within a week and they came back the
kids were already they found the way to
get online and they were using the
tablets and showing the younger kids
like the seven year olds are showing the
three year olds how to do it and and I
heard about this on Seth Godin podcast
akimbo and what what I thought about
there is like we we feel compelled by
the screen
and they can do really great things so
it's not it's not black and white it's
not buying an area we're all here
because of the internet you know that
it's been a great thing for us but it
can also be the greatest distraction
I've ever experienced in my life and the
tug of war is trying to eliminate the
distraction while using it for good I
loved what Derek Siver's said when he
chatted with you guys about like he said
the greatest gift I can give my child is
a long attention span yeah and I ever
since I listened that I just been
thinking about that constantly I've just
a how how much of like a superpower
that's gonna be for kids now too you
know if you can develop that twenty
years from now and it's very everyone
has short attention span that's gonna
feel like a superpower for them yeah but
then V how do you I mean everything is
fighting against that culture as you're
raising a kid and how do you start to
consciously think about you know how to
create that in them yeah I think what he
does is so admirable like world they'll
just go and spend an entire day at a
park and it's testing the limits of his
own attention span as well but I think
what happens when you removes the
distractions you you're able to do that
and I've gotten considerably better
especially with Ella and just because
for me I'm just like all right we've
gone to the beach we've seen the sunset
let's go go go right next thing and that
was programmed into me it probably as a
child but mainly in the corporate world
as well I just get the next thing done
go tasks tasks tasks tasks all right
sunset is done get in the car buckle up
we're driving to dinner and the next
thing in the you have sit get the ETA
yeah and you have like all of the next
things whereas Derek has removed the the
two dues so to speak and and and instead
he sort of has a to B list which is just
the present moment and that's it yeah
and yeah I really I really admire that
and well I don't hope to be perfect I
hope to get closer to that each time
that I I spend time with Ella and I
still catch myself I pull out my phone
or whatever and then I'm like what am i
doing
yeah Cal Newport I don't know if you're
familiar with his work he he did an
event with Ryan it was I was supposed to
be there but I was deathly ill and one
of the things that he wrote recently was
about the need for being a digital
grown-up and the thing that he talked
about this is so good in fact let me see
if I can it might still be a my
instapaper here I'll pull it up real
quick but basically what what he's
talking about is well here it's right
here digital wellness for grown-ups
we'll put a link to this in the show
notes as well earlier this week the
Washington Post published an article on
the digital wellness movement which
attempts to use technology to help cure
some of the issues caused by technology
by the way that seems a bit quixotic to
me like - yeah we're if we're just using
technology to - yeah it's like using a I
don't know it's like getting a paper cut
and then taping that piece of paper on
to you to heal the cut in a way this
movement for example is responsible for
an app that quote plants a tree each
time you put down your phone and then
shows the tree with a ring and dying
when you pick the phone back up it also
produced a popular plugin that displays
each time you go online the number of
days left and your expected lifetime
even Apple is getting involved in
digital wellness their new suite of
quote well-being features in iOS
includes a wakeup screen that helps you
quote gently ease into your day when
pick it when you pick up your phone in
the morning and then in an improved Siri
that makes suggestions about optimal
notification settings here's the optimal
notification settings turn them all yeah
that's optimal
I recognize that digital tools have a
useful role to play in productivity
I've long advised for example that
people use internet blocking blocking
software like freedom to help jumpstart
deep work training so Cal Newport book
is deep work we'll put a link to that
and the show notes as well because it's
well worth reading but something about
this growing digital wellness movement
makes me uneasy
and I think I finally put my finger on
the source of my concern it's
infantilizing this is so true I'm a
grown man if I if I'm checking my phone
every five minutes or playing video
games instead of paying attention to my
kids
I don't need an animation of a dying
treat and nudge me toward better better
habits I need someone I respect to knock
the stupid thing out of my hand and say
get your act together my sense is that
more and more people in our current
culture of digital excess are hungry for
this type of strong a challenge they
don't want to depend on Apple to tweak
their OS to be slightly less intrusive
or need to download an app that provides
a fun reminder about disconnecting they
want instead to be so wrapped up in
doing things that are hard and important
and meaningful that they forget where
they left their phone in the first place
there's something about these new
technologies and the screen zombie
lifestyle that surrounds them
that feels fundamentally childish this
is making people uneasy
that's because they're ready to grow up
and I think that man the the times where
I'm not even tempted by pacification or
distraction are those times of deep work
where I'm doing something that is deeply
satisfying writing for me is one of
those things or for podcasting we're
having these conversations I don't feel
like damn I need to check my email right
now yeah I wonder if I Kenny a text
message stop and check the news maybe
something happened what is Trump
tweeting about today yeah it's like okay
I mean the times that I feel compelled
to do that is the times where I feel
compelled to I want to I want to take
the path of least resistance that go
with the flow and the easy route oh yeah
I had my doctors on the podcast last
week and one of the things I was talking
to them about and this was fascinating
like I felt like the optimal time for my
health in my life or at least what I
thought would when I felt really good
was age 31 and then right around 34 35 I
started have a ton of health problems
I've worked really hard the last two
years to fix them and with
their help they've helped me out
immensely but I said one thing that I
still feel as sharp as I did when I was
at age 31 like I'm much closer right I
got to a point two years ago when I had
such bad brain fog I thought I was dying
I had a bunch of issues I'd c-diff and
which kills like 14,000 people a year
and and and so I had the set of problems
and I had bad brain fog and I've
recovered significantly from that but I
said I won't feel like sharp as I did
when I was 31 but then I also listened
to more podcasts than I've ever listened
to and I'm thinking like oh wait a
minute
like that's just another pacifier for me
like I and so this past week I went and
deleted like 90% of the podcast outlets
so I kept the ones that are like truly
essential for me the ones that I get
immense value from but I've spent the
last week listening to very few podcasts
and instead listening to music or just
not bringing my phone with me at all
when I go out for a walk and and using
that time to think and and I have felt a
sense of just a little bit more clarity
like incremental 3% more 5% more but
magic if that compounds over yeah
the course of a year or something I
think it'll be interesting to see how
podcasts impact time spent reading yeah
because it's a symbol I think it's a
symbol similar sort of neurological
response I'm like I'm getting this
information this information is valuable
but I do think it's I love podcasts but
I do think there is like a ton of value
psychologically there's lot of research
to show us that like reading is
important podcasts are listening is
fundamentally passive versus active yeah
and it'll be interesting you know if I
could read Cal Newports book or if I
could go us in the to podcast at the Cal
Newport in 10 years you know which
what's gonna be sort of the path of
least resistance I think it'll be
interesting to see you know if like if
reading on a subject becomes this like
very intentional act because just
passively listening is something while
you're doing work and catching the
tidbits is so much easier yeah well I
mean there's this weird sort of payoff
between going wide and going deep too I
mean Ryan and I we published three books
together and the the best we can hope
for is like a quarter million copies out
there in the world right which is fun
yeah yeah and and but if a quarter
million people don't listen to this
episode I would be devastated right so
it's this weird thing where we're all of
a sudden like you you have this this
this broader base of people but I think
the secret then with the the book it
can't be fluff exactly it has to go deep
it has to be meaningful and I'm really
encouraged by the new ways that we we
publish things now we as a society
because it used to be a book had to be
250 pages right because that way the
publisher could justify charging $40 for
this hard copy and and now it doesn't
have to be that way I look at you know a
dennis johnson book or a seth godin book
these are books are 120 pages sometimes
because it's whatever is necessary and
they cut the excess stuff out of it
right and i think we can do that now and
i think the same is true with with any
other work that we do it's much more
about going deep it's the reason why and
I and I can say this proudly we've never
had anything that has gone viral in the
sense that I know I I mean there are a
bunch of things I can think of that have
gone viral that quite often virality is
like a car crash though like people will
all turn their head and look but they're
not gonna stick around right when people
find out about the podcast they tend to
stick around or our website or the
documentary will lead them to other work
and then they can go deeper if they want
but if we ever had something that just
went truly went viral and hundreds of
millions of views somewhere that
wouldn't mean anything if people didn't
stick around it's very low yeah yeah
yeah and and and also the attention rate
is pretty low too right you get this
this burst of attention there's a study
I saw recently the average American
attention span now is 8 to 59 seconds
oh wow and so giving your kid the long
attention span just means greater than a
minute I guess at this point Wow well
you know we got to be careful man
because on every single screen that we
that we have that we own the screens
that we see whether it's a billboard or
a digital billboard whatever that when
we're driving down the road it is we're
in a society where
everyone is trying they're vying for our
attention yes like they're going out of
their way to distract us to distract us
to implant a thought in our head that's
gonna make us want to buy what they're
distracting us with yes and I think too
you know Cal Newports point like to be
an adult when it comes to this digital
age' we live in we have to be very
deliberate with all the screens that we
have in our homes and I think especially
with kids it's and it's such a easy
thing to give a kid to you know the kind
of babysit them for a little bit so and
I'm and you know there's nothing wrong
with TV there's nothing wrong with a
laptop or an iPad or whatever it may be
the problem is is when we are allowing
those those advertisements those
corporations to distract us to to
implant these really kind of needless
needs yeah well there's a reason that
the the rate of depression and Amish
society is nearly non-existent Wow yeah
and part of it has to do with the lack
of distractions and the amount of deep
work that is involved in everyday life
there and true focus and attention but
but it also has to do with setting up a
structure that is inherently meaningful
and I think about that now you don't
have to be Amish to set up those
structures but it becomes more difficult
as you say when when you're you have
these constant temptations in our in our
everyday life a lot of them it's our own
doing yeah I mean it's a lot of it is is
us yes that looks nice and shining we
want to get that but not realizing like
the the attention that it's going to
take away from us
you